les agriculteurs que nous sommes vivent
toujours dépendre de la nature
voilà c'est la crosse et une année ce
qu'on atteigne les 100 récolte et
blanche
[Musique]
[Rires]
au niveau français il est pas impossible
que l'on perde environ 30 % de la
récolte totale de la france donc on
parle de 12 à 15 millions d'hectolitres
en moins c'est l'équivalent de ce que la
france exporte à peu près chaque année
il ya des gens qui ont perdu 90% consent
certains de leurs vignes leur production
cette année surtout pour les vignerons
les petits vignerons travaillent
beaucoup avec les restaurants et donc
tous les restaurants sont fermés aux
morts
[Musique]
nous enclenchons le dispositif des
calamités agricoles permettant
d'apporter notamment dans le secteur de
l'arboriculteur l'arboriculture un
soutien financier
donc nous enclenchons ce dispositif de
calamité agricole
sans plus tarder pour faire en sorte que
ces accompagnements puisse arriver le
plus rapidement possible
[Musique]